hallo mein name ist willkommen wie heute
beim neuen video ich mal wieder bei
twitter gesagt dass ich mir irgendwelche
videos unter dem hashtag luca reagiert
werden soll dass zahlreiche tags darauf
reagiere ich heute um genau zu sein
wir fangen die regale der übrigens ich
habe wieder kein stativ deswegen stetig
haben auch ein paket also bisschen
komischen perspektive aber wir fangen
mit dem ersten video wird trifft im
klassement einfach durch die gegend und
auf einmal immer wenn ich in ein paar
sekunden später weiter mit dem nächsten
video effektiv die werke mit lukas shop
einblendungen ist halt so dass da der
medien leitfaden neuerdings sagte es ist
ja auch schon werbung auf wände und ein
eigener shop ist das ganze auch letzten
mal im video angesprochen dass ich quasi
selber werbevideo anmeldung und sie
wenden leute wegen leute kauft etwas
jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den de
[Musik]
ja ich war das früher immer ganz cool
dass man einfach sagen konnte
das kommt aus dem mund kommt der kabine
shop.de einwendung aber nicht mehr
erlaubt deswegen muss man da jetzt
handeln um der videos für das ist blöd
weil ich hatte deutschland
ich hätte nie damit gerechnet aber es
war heute wirklich der tag an dem die
talentierte videos eingeblendet wurden
also in dem gerade hat ja so ein mädel
purzelbäume und so gemacht und an der
stelle muss ich wirklich sagen ich habe
bisher nur purzelbäume witzigerweise
bald entweder auf einer masse gemacht
oder halt irgendwie ins wasser oder so
aber ich hab das noch nie auf trampolins
gemacht auch habe ich mega schön also
clever hält mich dass schnitt so ich
habe angst mit abgenickt verbrechen bei
den tollpatsch und da passiert dass er
häufig wurde
wenn man ins wasser fällt oder wenn man
findet auch vom trampolin essen und
wasser springt oder auch dünner luft
gefüllten matte im backkatalog
entgegenkommen der schwierigkeiten nicht
so nach dem motto aber ich war auch mal
in so einem trampolin tag und da habe
ich mal probiert und dann bin ich
irgendwie bereit auf der seite weil ich
kümmere mich einfach gemacht aber da
sollte man nicht über die schulter ab
und macht danach davon ob sie schon
darauf gedrängt so es war halt auch
nicht so cool also ich muss die tomate
das hat halt nicht so also es war halt
schon ein bisschen alles video
eigentlich mit einer mülltonne von
rechts nach links läuft
ich meine dass ich wieder zum komplette
hat statt wohin ein video wo jemand
wirklich auf einem sollte sich möge
gemacht und gesagt dass auch luca die
minikamera der film sich dann irgendwie
weitermachen
und da kommt dieser andere einbindung
war einfach über eine mülltonne von
rechts nach links sieht hammer
einblendung von 1 von 1
[Musik]
das nicht ernst
also ich glaube jedem sollte klar sein
dass ich dass es sich dabei um einen
plastik spielzeug penis handelt ich hab
euch das ganze trotzdem fan hier weil
youtube nicht weiß gehabt nicht ich weiß
ich muss meine videos gebracht werden
deswegen muss nicht weiter feuchten die
leute immer warum modern und wie kommt
man auch nicht zu sagen wenn ich kaufe
mir ein spielzeug classic gene stecken
in die hose und das trinken würde der
familie floh und dann schlug also ok ich
hab' das nur eingenommen aber in einer
mitteilung
danke für deinen gerichtsmedizin 5 jeden
tag hoch dankeschön
mir fällt nur schwierig was die
richtigen worte zu finden
ich sage mir sehr sehr viel schlafen
eingeblendet ob die nicht reagieren
sondern das mache ich auch auf weil es
lustig und ich bin das wird juni findet
das witzig und daraus bestätige format
ja auch irgendwie aber es kommen immer
so zwischendurch die einwendungen von
zuschauern und zuschauerinnen die
wirklich mich wirklich bayern und sie
sagen ja das mag ich bleib so wie du
bist und da muss ich einfach nur sagen
danke leute daumen hoch an euch lasst
ein like bei dem bio da vielleicht da
ist als community jappy peter hier eine
pizza jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den
blöcken de
[Musik]
warum ein video eingeschickt niemand
seine hand dafür im der in lyon trifft
im liegen
[Musik]
ich war vor ihr könnt so im bett liegen
und über euch etwas zu essen mit meiner
schwester zwei kaninchen dann ist ein
gestorben klopfer dieses glaube ich und
die hat sich schon schwer getan ganz so
war das wasser aus dem wasser heraus zu
trinken und diesen dazu getroffen und
hier haben da frisst waren liegen
derzeit einfach noch mehr als wir alle
schon schön
respekt ich fand keinen einradfahren
wird wieder so eine typische luca
reagieren folge der ich euch einfach
frage wie wenig ich kann keine seite auf
dem trampolin keine einradfahren liebe
like you can't leave you can ja ich hab
dich wieder gefunden
man verloren gegangen ja wieder gefunden
ich bin wieder gebunden schauen wir doch
mal anbieter aus der
ich bin enttäuscht du hast mich als
frosch wieder gefunden doch mal was ist
eigentlich mit diesem schein licht hier
draußen los ich bin gerade wieder bei
meinen eltern sonne und ich habe ja
keine beleuchtung sondern nur sondern
diese gefälschter freundlich und ich
finde aber auch die sonne angewiesen bei
der verrichtung letztlich die kamera ein
weil gerade schatten ist wird kombiniert
mit wir sind total komische farbe aber
egal also liebe darin ihre video
eingeblendet hat du hast mich
wiedergefunden und ich bin ein coach und
ich verlange verloren
warum bin ich ein frosch und war lange
verloren
in dem video he man eine pizza dreht
cool das was man geiles video und etwa
so lang und so motivieren können wir
noch mal schauen
leute was ich mir letztes mal überlegt
habe stellt euch mal vor ich würde eine
pizza aus bringen so mit smileys drauf
oder sogar mit einem großen zweite
kaufen las man leichter und schreibt für
die kommentare
weil eine deshalb ist irgendwie so die
wenig 23 eur 3 50 euro mehr obwohl ich
doch dann wenn alle nur noch gezeichnet
obwohl künstler natürlich auch weiß ist
ich weiß gar nicht ob das schon so kraft
öffentliches aber sie weiß es ja
anscheinend also ja ich bin wieder bei
der zertifizierung von in wien
dies sind drei wochen ja leute ich will
ein bahnticket april bei der step one
convention in wien fan treffen am
samstag der feind april also strafen
kalender tickets könnt ihr online kaufen
will sollte stattfinden also um seine
fragen zu beantworten ja ich bin bei dem
fantreffen in wien ich werde auch am
freitag schon ankommen und am sonntag
dann auch schon wieder fahren leider
aber ich freu mich schon unterwegs ins
netz geschickt
[Musik]
ebenfalls im heck und ich habe einfach
mit rein weil viele ja malen hale
uckermark am meer und durch die gegend
wie professionellen leuten oder
talentierten leuten die wirklichen war
das einsenden was ein mädchen
irgendwas mit ein bisschen leichtigkeit
beinhaltet also ich muss wirklich sagen
deine stimme ist schlimmer kann die
schön zu hören aber ich habe nichts
verstanden also ich weiß ja englisch
gesungen hast oder jede andere sprache
aber die zähne aus waren noch arbeiten
ich bin natürlich jetzt keinen
musikkritiker oder irgendein menschen
unglaublich viel ahnung hat aber ich
möchte natürlich auch meine freie
meinung sagen können hier deswegen ich
bin deine stimme megageil bedeutet auf
jeden fall machen aber ich hab's nicht
so ganz verstanden was du gesungen hat
kommt er doch schon zur letzten sendung
die keine wirkliche einbindung ist
sondern er wurde nur der link zu youtube
video geschickt in heftiger reagiert und
war wurde mir gesagt luca und ihr wurde
eine parodie gemacht
eine kopfsache die hochladen doch
einfach mal youtube-video 100 mal
zusammen
also um mit dem becken und infos dieser
typ hat mich nachgemachte dieses format
nachgemacht ok ich muss sagen denn der
macht es wirklich sehr sehr gut also was
ich kritisieren könnte wäre dass ich
halt mehr so bam bam bam bam schneider
also sehr schnell hintereinander er noch
ein bisschen zeit aber darauf geachtet
hat eine typische begrüßung dieses blöde
tore und halt auch dass die musik aus
redet wenn irgendetwas komisches
passiert wie beispielsweise wir schauen
ganz mal weiter an
wer hat dich das stationärer anwendung
mit reingenommen die auch mal luca
reagiert mit drin hatte und hat dann
weil sie so glücklich darauf reagiert
mit diesem buch mit dem kameramann
machen das macht ja sehr häufig einfach
so als übergang dass ihr veto gehen wenn
ich mit den rostocker dann eher so und
dann ist irgendwie dumm ist dann eher
weiter weg darauf hatte auch geachtet
und dann wieder diese typische kanadiers
david degen wird aber auf jeden fall
eine einsendung aber auch
okay das mache ich immer ich glaube in
jedem lokal gilt gewiss sehr habe ich
mindestens einmal gesagt also diese
einsendung das motiviert mich auf jeden
fall weiterhin die stücke aufzunehmen
denn lebt er jetzt kommt ein werbevideo
für den bürger - okay ich hab das machen
weil ich glaube wenn ich es gibt einen
pfad zwischen darauf aber ich glaube
wirklich es gibt keinen part wo ich
nicht gesagt habe ich nicht meine
merchandiser erwähnt habe wir schauen
dass wir das ende an
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den
business school
ja ich meine wer jetzt gedacht natürlich
nochmal meinen job eingeblendet aber
auch aber mit diesen klatschen am ende
mit dem tief hatte auch drin und dieses
mit seite dom oder sie haben etwas
teilen das also du hast gut gemacht ich
weiß nicht genau wie der kanal high aber
ich werde im auto verlinken
da wird auch schon vom video heute damen
und herren wenn euch das ganze volk da
wie gesagt auch ein leichter wenn ihre
kinder das öfter machen soll und wenn
doch eine pizza hätte und keine ahnung
warum also like community war legal sei
schreibt mal in die kommentare jetzt das
einzige wurde oder die ganze zeit
gewartet haben dieses wort habe ich fast
noch nie gesagt und war schreibt in die
kommentare reaktion
warum jetzt in zwei die eingebettet wenn
ihr auf könnte meinen kanal abonnieren
ist kostenlos jedoch keine videos mehr
solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal tun
darum findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet wird könnt ihr sachen von
mir kaufen wörtchen gleichzeitig
natürlich fans überlassen und hier unten
ein anderes video oder nicht